This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In high school Naomi Rothman was a shy teenager. That is, until she laced up her cleats and stepped on the field for her travel sockets. Surrounded by teammates she loved, Naomi became a completely different person. We were called the Red Hot Chili Peppers and it was very meaningful to me because I created these really strong friendships and it gave me a lot of confidence, it gave me a sense of self-worth and self-esteem and I really strongly identified with this team. There was just one catch. The players on this team predominantly came from the Eastside of town and played at Harbor High.
这是《隐藏的脑筋》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在高中时，娜奥米·罗斯曼曾是一个内向的青少年。直到她系紧鞋带，踏上她的旅行速成球队的球场。在喜爱的队友的环绕下，娜奥米变成了一个完全不同的人。我们被称为“红辣椒”，这对我意义重大，因为我结下了非常深厚的友谊，它给了我很多自信，给了我一种自我价值感和自尊心，我真的强烈认同这支球队。但有一个问题。这支球队的队员主要来自城东，并在港湾高中打球。
Naomi School, Santa Cruz High, was on the west side of our hometown of Santa Cruz, California. And so during our high school season, we had to play against each other and someone always had to lose. Harbor and Santa Cruz were always among the top contenders. And someone always had to lose. Harbor and Santa Cruz were always among the top contenders. The rivalry between the schools was intense. Every game we played against one another was high stakes and these games were some of the most emotionally fraught games that I ever played. And the reason was that I loved these players. I had this deep, genuine affection for the people that I was played. And the reason was that I loved these players. I had this deep, genuine
娜奥米所在的学校圣克鲁斯高中，位于我们加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯家乡的西侧。因此在我们的高中赛季，我们不得不互相比赛，而且总得有人输。港湾高中和圣克鲁斯高中一直名列前茅。而且总得有人输。港湾高中和圣克鲁斯高中一直名列前茅。学校之间的竞争非常激烈。我们彼此进行的每一场比赛都赌注极高，这些比赛是我所打过的最具情感张力的比赛。原因是我爱这些球员。我对那些与我比赛的人有着深厚、真挚的情感。原因是我爱这些球员。我有这种深厚、真挚的
affection for the people that I was trying to beat. The same player she had fought alongside as a member of the Red Hot Chili Peppers were now trying to crush her when Harbor High faced Santa Cruz. Her friends had become her frenemies. Naomi Rothman never forgot what that early experience felt like. Today, she's a psychologist who studies what happens to our minds when we feel like we are being emotionally pulled in opposite directions. It's absolutely, you know, an uncomfortable state. In fact, that will then kind of set the stage for how you engage with your environment, which is essentially to try to get rid of that feeling of discomfort.
对那些我试图击败的人的感情。曾经作为“红辣椒”成员并肩作战的同一名球员，现在当港湾高中对阵圣克鲁斯高中时，却试图击碎她。她的朋友变成了她的亦敌亦友。娜奥米·罗斯曼从未忘记那种早期体验的感觉。如今，她是一位心理学家，研究当我们感到自己在情感上被拉向相反方向时，我们的大脑会发生什么。你知道，这绝对是一种令人不舒服的状态。事实上，这会为你的环境互动方式奠定基础，本质上就是试图摆脱那种不适感。
The pain, paralysis, and promise of mixed emotions. This week on Hidden Brain. Sometimes we feel just one single feeling with overwhelming force. We are joyously happy. We are crushingly sad. But sometimes it's more complicated than that. We feel happy and sad at the same time. At Lehigh University, psychologist Naomi Rothman studies the mixed emotion of
矛盾情感的痛苦、瘫痪与希望。本周的《隐藏的脑筋》。有时我们只感受到一种压倒性的单一情感。我们欣喜若狂。我们痛彻心扉。但有时情况更加复杂。我们同时感到快乐和悲伤。在利哈伊大学，心理学家娜奥米·罗斯曼研究了
ambivalence. She explores how ambivalence changes the way we think and how it changes the way others see us. Naomi Rothman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me here with you. Naomi, you have a young daughter and she recently told us she wanted a hot new toy called a Magic Mixies cauldron. What is a Magic Mixies cauldron and what was your reaction to her request? Apparently this is a toy where there's a special wand that allows you to mix a potion, and it creates a mist to rise in this cute little furry friend called a magic mixy, appears through the mist. And all she really wants is this toy, and all of her friends are obsessed with this toy. It's kind of constantly on their minds. And when I looked up online, kind of the reviews,
矛盾心理这种混合情感。她探讨了矛盾心理如何改变我们的思维方式，以及它如何改变别人对我们的看法。娜奥米·罗斯曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的脑筋》。非常感谢邀请我来这里和你交流。娜奥米，你有一个年幼的女儿，她最近告诉我们她想要一个很火的新玩具，叫做魔法米克斯大锅。什么是魔法米克斯大锅，你对她的请求有什么反应？显然这是一个玩具，里面有一根特殊的魔杖，允许你混合魔药，它会在这个被称为魔法米克斯的可爱毛茸茸小玩偶周围产生升腾的雾气，通过雾气出现。她真正想要的就是这个玩具，她所有的朋友都对这个玩具着迷。这似乎是他们脑子里 constantemente（不断）盘旋的事情。当我上网查看评论时，
which is what I always typically do, I was completely embevelent. There are all these complaints that the potion leaks, that it stains your rug, it's a total waste of money, and it's like this one and done activity. Naomi had mixed feelings about getting the toy, but then she started hearing from other moms. They were going to great lengths to get it during a time of limited inventory.
这也是我通常会做的，我完全陷入了矛盾之中。有各种各样的投诉称魔药会泄漏，会弄脏你的地毯，完全是浪费钱，而且就像是一次性的活动。娜奥米对买这个玩具感到矛盾，但随后她开始听到其他妈妈们的消息。在库存有限的时期，她们为了得到它不惜付出巨大努力。
I actually had a friend who texted me that she was at Target waiting for the shipment to be unboxed because she was told that they might actually have a delivery of a few of these. And this is a working mother who's basically hanging out at Target to get one of these cauldrons. She's not in Bivalin at all, right? She's completely committed.
实际上有个朋友给我发短信说她在塔吉特等着开箱发货，因为她被告知他们可能真的会到货几个。这是一个全职妈妈，基本上在塔吉特闲逛就是为了买到其中一个大锅。她一点也不矛盾，对吧？她完全投入了。
I ultimately decided to go ahead and get it, but that was after a whole lot of vacillation. And lo and behold, by the time I actually pulled the trigger, the prices had skyrocketed, and it's totally sold out at all of our local target stores. And my lack of action is going to cost me either time. I'm going to have to go hang out and target for this next shipment. It's going to cost me in terms of money. Or it's going to cost me in terms of my daughter's happiness. I want to look at another moment in your life, perhaps with slightly more serious stakes,
我最终决定去买下它，但那是经过了一番犹豫不决之后。不出所料，当我真正下定决心时，价格已经飙升，而且我们当地所有的塔吉特商店都完全卖光了。我的不作为将让我付出时间的代价。我得去塔吉特闲逛等下一批货。这将在金钱上让我付出代价。或者这将在我女儿的快乐上让我付出代价。我想看看你生活中的另一个时刻，也许赌注稍微更严重一些，
where you also felt ambivalence. You were working on a project with several other colleagues when you experienced a rather severe bout of ambivalence. What happened and how did your colleagues receive your ambivalence? I had this really great opportunity to convene a group of world-class academics to work on a project on ambivalence? I had this really great opportunity to convene of group of world class academics to work on a project on ambivalence. And this was a really big deal for me
你也感到了矛盾。你当时正和几个同事合作一个项目，经历了一阵相当严重的矛盾心理。发生了什么，你的同事们是如何看待你的矛盾心理的？我当时有一个绝佳的机会召集一群世界级的学者来做一个关于矛盾心理的项目？我当时有一个绝佳的机会召集一群世界级的学者来做一个关于矛盾心理的项目。对我来说，这真是一件大事
because I'm bringing together experts in different areas of research. And as coming up as an academic, you look up to other scholars, right? These like older academic brothers and sisters or aunts and uncles, whatever you wanna call them. And here I got to work with them on my area of expertise. They were giving me a seat at their table and I was an expert.
因为我在汇聚不同研究领域的专家。作为一名初出茅庐的学者，你仰慕其他学者，对吧？这些年长的学术兄弟姐妹或叔叔阿姨，无论你怎么称呼他们。在这里，我有机会与他们在我的专业领域合作。他们给了我一张桌子旁的座位，而我是专家。
So everything starts off great, it's really generative, if you're really good about what's going on. But then it starts to take a little bit of a turn because we're going into areas that I know more about than they do. And I realize this. And so there's this pressure because on the one hand I feel in some ways subordinate to them. But on the other hand, this is my meeting, right? And what happens when the conversation starts to veer is that I feel
所以一切都从头开始很好，非常富有成效，你对发生的事情感觉很好。但随后事情开始发生了一点转变，因为我们进入了比他们了解更多的领域。我意识到了这一点。因此存在着一种压力，因为一方面我在某种程度上觉得我从属于他们。但另一方面，这是我的会议，对吧？当谈话开始偏离时，发生的事情是我觉得
like I have three options, right? On one hand, I have this choice I can remain silent. But a second choice is to play the cheerleader, right? Hey, Grez, this is great. Keep it going. No wrong answers here. And I felt like a third option is to tell them what I really thought, which was complex. And it's essentially like showing my ambivalence
我有三种选择，对吧？一方面，我可以选择保持沉默。但第二个选择是扮演拉拉队员，对吧？嘿，格雷兹，这太棒了。继续保持。这里没有错误的答案。我觉得第三个选择是告诉他们我的真实想法，这很复杂。这本质上就像展示我的矛盾心理
because my sentiments at the time were very positive and negative, right? And so I was thinking to myself, ultimately, this is a conversation about ambivalence, and so ambivalence should be honored here. And I didn't want this miss out on this opportunity to create something great with these really esteemed scholars. Naomi tentatively entered the discussion.
因为我当时的感情既有非常积极的也有非常消极的，对吧？所以我心里在想，归根结底，这是一场关于矛盾心理的对话，所以在这里应该尊重矛盾心理。我不想错过这个与这些备受尊敬的学者共同创造伟大成果的机会。娜奥米试探性地加入了讨论。
Instead of cheerleading or criticizing, she hesitantly expressed her mixed feelings. The intervention backfired. The unintended consequences of showing my ambivalence in this meeting is that it indicated my indecision. It indicated a lack of assertiveness or dominance. And it actually invited others in this meeting to take charge of the conversation, but this was supposed to be my party, this was supposed to be my meeting, and that was a kind of a difficult outcome to stomach.
她没有加油打气也没有批评，而是犹豫着表达了她复杂的感受。干预适得其反。在这场会议中表现出我的矛盾心理的意想不到的后果是，它表明了我的优柔寡断。它表明了缺乏自信或主导地位。它实际上邀请了会议中的其他人来掌控谈话，但这本该是我的派对，这本该是我的会议，这是一个有点难以接受的结果。
And in some ways, this matches what you have found in some of your research, when people view others who express ambivalence, they actually look down on them or potentially even want to take advantage of them. Yeah, so in the first few studies for my dissertation, I showed that people tend to have negative perceptions of those who are ambivalent. So those who are expressing that they feel tension and conflict about something, and that's
在某些方面，这与你在自己的一些研究所发现的一致，当人们看到表达矛盾心理的人时，他们实际上会看不起他们，甚至可能想利用他们。是的，所以在我的博士论文的前几项研究中，我表明人们往往对表现出矛盾心理的人抱有负面看法。所以那些表达自己对某事感到紧张和冲突的人，而那是
a result of their mixed emotions. People are more likely to see that ambivalent person compared to a happy person, an angry person, a neutral person, as less dominant, less confident, and less assertive. And what I found in those studies was that the reaction to perceiving ambivalent person in that way is that they had this intention to take control and they even took more money from the ambivalent person in that way is that they had this intention to take control. And they even took more money from the ambivalent partner than they took from the angry and the neutral partner. And I'm thinking this must also be the case when we interact with, you know, experts
他们混合情感的结果。与快乐的人、愤怒的人、中立的人相比，人们更有可能认为那个矛盾的人支配性更低、自信心更低、也更不自信。我在这些研究中发现，对这种感知到矛盾的人的反应是，他们有控制局面的意图，他们甚至从那个矛盾的伙伴那里拿走了更多的钱，其方式就是他们有这种控制局面的意图。而且他们从矛盾的伙伴那里拿走的钱甚至比从愤怒和中立的伙伴那里拿走的还要多。我想当我们与……互动时，这一定也是这样。各种各样的专家。
of all kinds. When I go and talk with a doctor, for example, I expect the doctor to be decisive to say, you know, here's what's wrong, here's what we should do. And if the doctor expresses ambivalence, I start to question, is this really a good doctor? I think you're really onto something there. And we've collected some data on that very question. With Jessica Marsh, who's also at Lehigh University,
例如，当我去和医生交谈时，我期望医生是果断的，会说，你知道，这是怎么回事，我们该怎么做。如果医生表现出矛盾心理，我就会开始质疑，这真的是一个好医生吗？我想你真的切中了要点。我们在那个确切的问题上收集了一些数据。与同样在利哈伊大学的杰西卡·马什一起，
we showed that when people read a scenario about a physician who was ambivalent, they were torn and conflicted. The patients presenting symptoms for both infection A and infection B. That in fact, those physicians were rated as more indecisive, as less well-informed, as lower in job performance, and people were less likely to say that they would follow their advice. And so I think you're right that there's a sense
我们表明，当人们阅读关于一个优柔寡断的医生的情景时，他们感到纠结和冲突。患者表现出感染A和感染B的症状。事实上，那些医生被评为更加优柔寡断、见识更少、工作表现更差，而且人们更不可能说他们会遵循他们的建议。所以我想你是对的，有一种感觉
that we consult experts to produce decisions, and if an expert signals their lack of ability to decide, we tend to lose faith in their expertise. One of the fascinating studies that you have done looks at the way leaders of companies are judged during earnings calls when they express ambivalence. Can you tell me about this research and what you found Naomi? We were really interested in what are the implications of a CEO expressing
我们咨询专家是为了做出决定，如果专家表现出他们缺乏做决定的能力，我们往往会失去对他们专业知识的信任。你所做的其中一项迷人研究着眼于公司高管在财报电话会议上表达矛盾心理时如何受到评价。你能告诉我这项研究以及你发现了什么，娜奥米吗？我们对CEO表达
emotional ambivalence in an earnings call, in particular with relation to how the analysts respond to their ambivalence in terms of the way they show skepticism. And so what we did was we collected data from earnings calls, we coded it using a text analysis software, and lo and behold what we found is that indeed, you know, leaders who show their ambivalence in an earnings calls, CEOs, CFOs, receive more skepticism from the analysts
情感矛盾在财报电话会议上有何影响非常感兴趣，特别是与分析师如何以表现出怀疑的方式对他们的矛盾做出反应有关。所以我们所做的是从财报电话会议中收集数据，使用文本分析软件对其进行编码，不出所料，我们发现的确，你知道，在财报电话会议中表现出矛盾的领导者，CEO，CFO，会受到分析师的更多怀疑
and from the marketplace, and that women, this effect is enhanced for women executives. And so these executives, when they express ambivalence, they invite more harsh questioning. They face what you call a scrutiny penalty. The performance of that company is examined and judged more harshly.
以及来自市场的怀疑，对于女性高管来说，这种效应会加剧。因此，这些高管在表达矛盾心理时，会招致更严厉的质问。他们面临着你所谓的审视惩罚。该公司的业绩受到更严厉的审视和评判。
Exactly. So what is true, of course, in the realm of business, is probably triply true in the realm of politics. Politicians certainly are expected to be decisive and confident. People who are president, or people who are running for president, are expected to know precisely what they think on every issue. I want to play you a political attack ad from some years ago that targeted then US Senator John Kerry, who was running for president in 2004.
没错。所以在商业领域如此的事情，在政治领域可能更是如此的三倍。人们当然期望政治家是果断和自信的。人们期望总统，或者竞选总统的人，确切地知道他们对每一个问题的看法。我想给你们播放一段几年前的政治攻击广告，针对当时的美国参议员约翰·克里，他在2004年竞选总统。
In which direction would John Kerry lead? Kerry voted for the Iraq War, opposed it, supported it, and now opposes it again. He bragged about voting for the 87 billion to support our troops before he voted against it. He voted for education reform and now opposes it. He claims he's against increasing Medicare premiums, but voted five times to do so. John Kerry, whichever way the win blows. And I remember this ad from the time it ran back in 2004 Naomi. And I remember it really
约翰·克里会把我们带向哪个方向？克里投票支持伊拉克战争，反对它，支持它，现在又再次反对它。他吹嘘自己投票支持870亿美元来支持我们的军队，然后又投票反对它。他投票支持教育改革，现在又反对它。他声称自己反对提高医疗保险保费，但却投票五次这样做。约翰·克里，风吹哪边倒向哪边。我记得2004年这则广告播出时的情景，娜奥米。我记得它真的
was a devastating ad because it painted John Kerry as someone who really didn't know his own mind, someone who was, you know, wishy-washy, who would basically go whichever way the wind blows. What do you think adds like this say about how we view ambivalent political leaders? Yeah, so I think that that's a wonderful example, right, of how there can be some liabilities for leaders in sharing their ambivalence. Everyone wants a leader to be black and white, because otherwise they might look inauthentic if they changed and were inconsistent.
是一个毁灭性的广告，因为它把约翰·克里描绘成一个根本不知道自己想法的人，一个你知道的模棱两可的人，风吹哪边就倒向哪边。你认为像这样的广告说明了我们如何看待矛盾的政治领导人？是的，所以我觉得这是一个极好的例子，说明了领导者分享他们的矛盾可能会带来一些负面影响。每个人都希望领导者非黑即白，因为否则如果他们改变且不一致，他们看起来可能就不真实。
And there's evidence that says, we would like a dominant leader, right? We think that they're gonna help us and provide us with certainty about how to act. And it's very interesting to notice that that does seem to have emerged as the prototypical model of what it looks like to be a leader. You know, so we've talked about how ambivalence can cause us to miss out on hot Christmas deals or cause our colleagues to get upset with us.
有证据表明，我们想要一个强势的领导者，对吧？我们认为他们会帮助我们并为我们如何行动提供确定性。非常有趣的是，这似乎已经成为领导者模样的原型模型。你知道的，所以我们讨论了矛盾如何导致我们错过圣诞节的火爆促销，或者导致我们的同事对我们生气的。
We've looked at how we judge leaders poorly if they express ambivalence. Besides all these effects, can we talk a moment about the subjective experience of ambivalence? I feel like in my own life, when I have felt torn, this is often an unpleasant feeling. I don't necessarily enjoy feeling ambivalent about things. Absolutely. It's considered to be an uncomfortable state. In fact, there's decades of research in the attitude ambivalence literature that draws on dissonance theory, which
我们研究了如果领导者表现出矛盾，我们如何对他们进行不好的评价。除了所有这些影响，我们能花一点时间谈谈矛盾的主观体验吗？我觉得在我自己的生活中，当我感到纠结时，这通常是一种不愉快的感觉。我对事情感到矛盾并不一定觉得愉快。绝对是的。它被认为是一个令人不舒服的状态。事实上，在态度矛盾文献中有数十年的研究借鉴了认知失调理论，该理论
assumes that when you have an inconsistent state, perhaps like attitude ambivalence, you're going to be feeling pretty uncomfortable, feeling torn and conflicted, and that that will then kind of set the stage for how you engage with your environment, which is essentially to try to get rid of that feeling of discomfort. So, there's a long history of research that has really established that ambivalences
假设当你处于一种不一致的状态时，也许就像态度矛盾一样，你会觉得相当不舒服，感到纠结和冲突，然后这将会为你是如何与你的环境互动奠定基础，本质上就是试图摆脱那种不适感。因此，有一长串的研究真正确立了矛盾心理
is quite an uncomfortable state. When we come back, what Naomi's research shows about the surprising upsides of ambivalence. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Ambivalence has many downsides. It's personally uncomfortable, it irritates our friends and colleagues, it even encourages others to take advantage of us. When we express ambivalence, people may think we are less competent already for leadership. But it turns out that is hardly the whole story.
是一种相当不舒服的状态。当我们回来时，娜奥米的研究展示了矛盾心理令人惊讶的好处。你在收听《隐藏的脑筋》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的脑筋》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。矛盾心理有很多消极面。它让人感到个人不适，它激怒了我们的朋友和同事，它甚至鼓励别人利用我们。当我们表达矛盾心理时，人们可能会认为我们在领导力方面已经不那么胜任了。但事实证明，这绝不是全部。
Naomi, you've given me a couple of examples from your life when ambivalence did not produce salutary outcomes, but I want you to tell me a story about a time when you deliberately ignored your ambivalence. Tell me about your real estate adventure in Bucks County, Pennsylvania. When my husband and I got married, we had both lived in New York City
娜奥米，你给了我几个你生活中的例子，说明矛盾并没有产生有益的结果，但我想让你讲一个关于你刻意忽视自己矛盾的故事。跟我讲讲你在宾夕法尼亚州巴克斯县的房地产奇遇吧。我和我丈夫结婚时，我们都已经在纽约市
for about 10 years each. And this is 10 years of living in small apartments, overpaying rent, dealing with roommates. We both really wanted to own a home. So we took trips out to the country on weekends. We kind of daydreamed about the idyllic life, living in a rural environment with these like beautiful old colonial farm houses.
各自生活了大约10年。这是住在小公寓里、支付过高的租金、应付室友的10年。我们俩都非常想拥有一套房子。所以我们在周末去乡下旅行。我们有点白日梦般地想象着田园般的生活，生活在一个乡村环境中，有着美丽古老的殖民地农舍。
And we finally found a place that we felt like was us. We fell in love with this house. It was this like remodeled farmhouse in Bucks County just above the Delaware River. It had been remodeled by a designer from New York and it just really aesthetically appealed to both of our tastes. But at the time, I actually had these strong feelings that we might be jumping into something that we hadn't fully weighed the pros and cons on, but I didn't share this with my husband. And it turns out my husband was also ambivalent, but he just didn't share this with me either. And the reality was that we were not prepared for country living, for a whole number of reasons, right? One is, it took my husband over two hours,
我们终于找到了一个我们觉得属于我们的地方。我们爱上了这座房子。它就像是巴克斯县特拉华河上方的一座改建农舍。它是由一位来自纽约的设计师改建的，在美学上完全吸引了我们的品味。但当时，我其实有强烈的预感，我们可能是在没有充分权衡利弊的情况下仓促行事，但我没有把这告诉我的丈夫。事实证明，我丈夫也很矛盾，但他也没有把这告诉我。现实情况是，由于各种原因，我们根本没有为乡村生活做好准备，对吧？第一，我丈夫通勤需要花两个多小时，
one way to get to his job in New York City. Oh my God. Two, just like you don't get to choose your coworkers, you don't get to choose all of your neighbors. Three, it was a quite small home. Family couldn't visit very comfortably. It was off the road, a road that floods. We knew nobody out there.
单程去他在纽约市的工作地点。哦，天哪。第二，就像你不能选择你的同事一样，你不能选择你所有的邻居。第三，这是一栋相当小的房子。家人来访住得不是很舒服。它离一条会发洪水的路很近。我们在那里谁也不认识。
And neither of us had actually owned a home, right? Let alone lived in the country. And nor did we know how to take care of this beautiful and expansive garden. And we had the groundhogs, we had rodents, we had deer, we had trees that fell down. We had bamboo that took over our, you know, front yard every year. We had pebbles in the driveway that would wash into the road every time it rained. We had to literally rake it with our own hands. Like every time this happened, we were just in so over our heads. We went actually over our budget to purchase it even though we could see some of these
而且我们俩实际上都没有拥有过房子，更不用说在乡村生活了。我们也不知道如何照顾这个美丽而广阔的花园。我们有土拨鼠，我们有啮齿动物，我们有鹿，我们有倒下的树。我们有竹子每年占领我们的前院。每次下雨，我们车道上的鹅卵石都会被冲到路上。每次发生这种情况，我们都不得不亲自动手用耙子清理。就像每次发生这种情况时，我们都完全不知所措。我们甚至超出了预算去购买它，尽管我们可以看到其中的一些
downsides, right? We leaped because we wanted stability and we wanted closure on this long search and in our lives and we were ignoring the negative cues. And in the end, it was not a great choice for us. We essentially lived so far away from my spouse's work that he had to couch surf during the week in New York City at Friends Houses, because the commute was unbearably long. I ended up having a daughter in 2015 and 2016.
缺点，对吧？我们迈出这一步是因为我们想要稳定，想要在这漫长的寻找中以及我们的生活中画上句号，而我们忽视了消极的信号。最后，这对我们来说并不是一个好选择。我们基本上住得离我配偶的工作地点太远了，以至于他不得不在周间在纽约市的朋友家沙发客，因为通勤时间长得无法忍受。我最终在2015年和2016年生了一个女儿。
I was up for tenure. I was raising her, she was a for tenure. I was raising her. She was a toddler. And I was pregnant with our second kid. And my spouse couldn't even come home during the week. So we sold the house four years after purchasing it, of course, in a loss. And again, I wanted closure.
我当时在争取终身教职。我在抚养她，她当时在争取终身教职。我在抚养她。她还是个幼儿。我怀上了我们的第二个孩子。我的配偶甚至不能在周间回家。所以在购买这栋房子四年后，我们把它卖了，当然是亏本出售。再次强调，我想要一个句号。
I wanted my family to be together. I wanted to not be lonely that I just had to get out. The story in many ways matches what your research has found in terms of the effect that ambivalence has on the way we make judgments. In one of your studies, you primed participants' emotional state by having them write about a time when they felt happy, sad, or ambivalent, and then you gave them an estimation task. You asked them to estimate the average daily temperature in major US cities like New York, Atlanta, and San Francisco. What did you find when you had them do this?
我希望我的家人能在一起。我希望不再孤独，我只想离开。这个故事在很多方面与你的研究发现相吻合，关于矛盾对我们做出判断方式的影响。在你的其中一项研究中，你通过让参与者写下他们感到快乐、悲伤或矛盾的时刻来启动他们的情绪状态，然后你给他们一个估算任务。你让他们估算美国主要城市（如纽约、亚特兰大和旧金山）的平均日气温。当让他们做这件事时，你发现了什么？
And what do we find in general, ambivalence produces in terms of the way people approach decisions? Yeah, so this was some interesting work I did with Laura Reese, Ruben Lee Havie, and Jerryries Senges-Berks, who were all at Michigan at the time. And we primed people to feel emotional and bifilms. We had them recall a time in their life where they felt really mixed, really happy and sad at the same time, and to really write about this experience so that they could relive the experience and that somebody who was reading it would also relive that experience along with them, right? We were really trying to put them in that state.
我们在总体上发现，矛盾在人们接近决策的方式方面产生了什么？是的，这是我和劳拉·里斯、鲁本·李·哈维以及杰里·森格斯-伯克斯合作的一些有趣的工作，他们当时都在密歇根大学。我们引导人们去感受情绪上的矛盾。我们让他们回忆他们生命中感到非常纠结的时刻，同时感到非常高兴和悲伤，并真正写下这段经历，以便他们能够重温这段经历，阅读它的人也会和他们一起重新体验这段经历，对吧？我们真的在试图让他们进入那种状态。
And then we did a series of studies where we explored whether, you know, priming people to feel mixed emotions made them more open and receptive to peer advice. And then we had them do these tasks, these estimation tasks, that were unrelated to the ambivalence that they were experiencing, right, about the weather, you know, about college tuition rates, things that they might not have known a whole lot about. And we found that, in fact, though, in behold,
然后我们做了一系列研究，探讨引导人们感受混合情感是否能让他们更加开放和乐于接受同伴的建议。然后我们让他们做这些任务，这些估算任务，这些任务与他们正在经历的矛盾无关，对吧，关于天气，关于大学学费比例，他们可能不太了解的事情。我们发现，事实上，出乎意料的是，
private people to have mixed feelings, not only made them more open and receptive to peer advice, but also more accurate in their estimates. And the way we describe this was that our emotions, perhaps lead us to be biased in particular ways, right? But that if you have multiple emotions, the error in the bias can be canceled out. And therefore, in fact, it can make us more accurate
引导人们产生混合感受，不仅让他们更加开放和乐于接受同伴的建议，而且使他们的估计更加准确。我们对此的描述是，我们的情绪可能会以特定的方式导致我们产生偏见，对吧？但如果你有多种情绪，偏见中的错误可以被相互抵消。因此，事实上，它可以让我们在对世界的预测、估计和判断中更加准确。
in our predictions, in our estimates about the world and our judgments. So much of this is premised on the idea that our emotions in some ways are providing us with signals. So when our emotions tell us something, they tell us how to respond to the world, how to behave in the world, how to walk in the world. And I think what you're showing with these studies is that ambivalence itself actually
这一切的很大一部分都建立在这样一个概念之上，即我们的情绪在某种程度上为我们提供了信号。因此，当我们的情绪告诉我们某些事情时，它们是在告诉我们如何对世界做出反应，如何在世界上表现，如何在世界上行走。我认为你通过这些研究展示的是，矛盾本身实际上
is not just a state of uncertainty, it's actually a signal of how we ought to behave in the world. Yeah, I think that's really well said. There's an approach to the study of emotions by Schwartz and Chlor who argued that affect his information, that when we have emotions, that it actually provides us with information, right, in about our environment, and that emotions are actually here for a reason. And if you pay attention to your emotional cues, it can signal perhaps an appropriate response to the challenges that you might be facing.
不仅仅是一种不确定的状态，它实际上是我们应该如何在世界上表现的信号。是的，我认为这说得非常好。施瓦茨和克洛尔对情绪研究有一种方法，他们认为情感就是信息，当我们有情绪时，它实际上为我们提供了关于我们环境的信息，而且情绪的存在确实是有原因的。如果你注意你的情绪线索，它可能会提示对你可能面临的挑战做出适当的反应。
And so we know that from a whole large, beautiful body of work by Jeff Larson that makes the motions, emotional ambivalence tend to be triggered by pretty emotionally complex situations like college graduation day, dormitory and move out day, watching the movie life is beautiful, and the movie Life is Beautiful, and that these are pretty contradictory, complex situations. So one thought that Shimon Mawani and I have written about is,
因此，我们从杰夫·拉森的一大批精彩研究中知道，混合情感，情感矛盾往往由相当复杂的感情情境触发，比如大学毕业典礼、宿舍搬迁日、观看电影《美丽人生》、电影《美丽人生》，这些都是相当矛盾、复杂的情景。因此，西蒙·马瓦尼和我写过的一个想法是，
maybe emotional ambivalence exists in part to help us solve contradictory and complex problems. Another way to put this perhaps might be is that one of the functions of an emotion-like ambivalence is to protect us against impulsive decisions. I think that's absolutely right. In fact, I'm conducting right now meta-analysis with some scholars at UT Austin, where we're really trying
也许情感矛盾的存在部分是为了帮助我们解决矛盾和复杂的问题。换一种方式来表达这也许是，像矛盾这样的情绪的功能之一就是保护我们免受冲动的决定。我认为这绝对是正确的。事实上，我目前正在与得克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的一些学者进行一项元分析，在那里我们真的在试图
to unpack the conditions under which ambivalence yields greater learning and exploration versus the conditions under which it leads to less exploration and learning. And one of the things that we have identified is that in this closure imperative, the desire to have an answer, get closure on a decision, move forward in our lives, we really
剖析矛盾产生更多学习和探索的条件，以及导致较少探索和学习的条件。我们已经确定的一件事是，在这种关闭的急迫性中，对得到答案、对决定做个了结、在生活中前进的渴望，我们确实
made do less exploration of the information that exists in our world. But guess what? Under low closure imperative, you do more exploration and learning. So being in an ambivalent state of mind changes the way we think in a range of different ways. I want to play you a clip from the movie Father of the Bride in the scene, the actor Steve Martin is playing a dad whose daughter is about to get married. I realized at that moment that I was never going to come home again and see Annie at the top of the stairs. Never going to see her again at our breakfast table in her nightgown and socks. I suddenly realized what was happening. Annie was all grown up and leaving us. And something inside began to hurt.
对我们世界中存在的信息进行了较少的探索。但你猜怎么着？在低关闭急迫性下，你会进行更多的探索和学习。因此，处于矛盾的心态会以各种不同的方式改变我们的思维方式。我想给你播放电影《新岳父大人》的一个片段，在这一幕中，演员史蒂夫·马丁扮演一位女儿即将结婚的父亲。我当时意识到我再也不会回家看到安妮在楼梯顶上了。再也看不到她穿着睡衣和袜子坐在我们的早餐桌旁。我突然意识到发生了什么。安妮已经完全长大了，要离开我们了。内心深处有什么东西开始隐隐作痛。
So Naomi, researchers have used this movie clip to give people a sense of what it's like to feel and build a lens. Can you tell me by the research experiments they've conducted and what they found? Yeah, so this is the kind of foundational research on emotional ambivalence at Christina Fong conducted. What she was able to do was prime people to feel emotional ambivalence through clips like this and then had them engage in creativity tasks. And this is the work that has very much inspired a lot
所以娜奥米，研究人员利用这个电影片段来让人们体会感受矛盾是什么感觉。你能告诉我他们进行的研究实验以及他们发现了什么吗？是的，这是克里斯蒂娜·方进行的关于情感矛盾的基础研究。她所做的是通过这样的片段引导人们感受情感矛盾，然后让他们参与创造力任务。这项工作极大地启发了许多
of the scholarship on the benefits of emotional ambivalence, particularly for cognitive flexibility and other outcomes like that. What she was able to show was that priming people to feel mixed emotions tells people that they may be in an unusual environment and that it cues to them unusual associations in subsequent tasks that they engage in. And we've done some research recently
关于情感矛盾好处的学术研究，特别是针对认知灵活性和其他类似结果的研究。她能够展示的是，引导人们感受混合情感告诉人们他们可能处于一个不寻常的环境中，并且它在他们随后参与的任务中提示了不寻常的联想。我们最近做了一些研究
where we've shown that I'm feeling emotional and prevalence makes you more cognitively flexible. And what I mean by that is that you not only think about concepts in a more broad and inclusive way, if you're feeling ambivalent, you'll actually process information in a more cognitive, flexible manner. In other words, when we feel ambivalence, our minds are processing a situation that feels complicated. When we shut down ambivalence, we can shut down thinking in complex ways about an issue. We start to prioritize decisiveness over accuracy.
我们已经证明，感受情感矛盾会让你在认知上更加灵活。我的意思是，如果你感到矛盾，你不仅会以更广泛和包容的方式思考概念，你实际上会以更具认知灵活性的方式处理信息。换句话说，当我们感到矛盾时，我们的大脑正在处理一个感觉复杂的情况。当我们关闭矛盾时，我们可能会停止以复杂的方式思考一个问题。我们开始把果断置于准确性之上。
There's another important insight here. When we permit ambivalence, we can also change how the people around us are thinking. Naomi has found that people who express ambivalence can help to move negotiation partners to what a result that works well for everyone. Yes, so the research I conducted initially that people react kind of dominantly towards their ambivalent partner particularly when they're in these competitive negotiations, right? Where my win is your loss, your loss is my win. But I wasn't satisfied completely with that answer. And so I set out to examine with drug northcraft,
这里还有另一个重要的见解。当我们允许矛盾存在时，我们也可以改变我们周围人的思维方式。娜奥米发现，表达矛盾的人可以帮助推动谈判伙伴达成对每个人都效果很好的结果。是的，所以我最初进行的研究表明，人们对他们的矛盾伙伴会有支配性的反应，特别是在这些竞争性谈判中，对吧？在那里，我的赢就是你的输，你的输就是我的赢。但我对这个答案并不完全满意。所以我着手与德鲁·诺思克拉夫特一起检查，
what happens when you change the social norms? What happens when you actually encourage people to cooperate with their ambivalent counterpart? Does ambivalents have a different effect in that more cooperative setting? And I trained an actor from the two school of arts to express ambivalence, she was torn, conflicted in her nonverbal behavior.
当你改变社会规范时会发生什么？当你真正鼓励人们与他们的矛盾对手合作时会发生什么？在那种更具合作性的背景下，矛盾会有不同的效果吗？我从两所艺术学校培训了一名演员来表达矛盾，她在非语言行为中表现得纠结、冲突。
And I had negotiators watch a video of this partner before they engaged in negotiation with her and report their perceptions of her. She was perceived just as in my prior studies as less dominant. But in the negotiations with cooperative goals where I want to win, but not at your expense, that ambivalence in that context, in fact, inspired better outcomes. But it seems like it has to do with setting a cooperative context to create social norms where we're sitting actually on the same side of the table, that we realize that this is
我让谈判人员在与她进行谈判之前观看这段合作伙伴的视频，并报告他们对她的看法。正如我之前的研究一样，她被认为不那么具有支配性。但在具有合作目标的谈判中，我想要赢，但不是以牺牲你为代价，在这种背景下的矛盾，实际上激发了更好的结果。但看起来这与建立合作背景有关，以创造社会规范，即我们实际上坐在桌子的同一边，我们意识到这是一个
a complex problem, we're working independently, and that that's precisely the situation where your ambivalence makes me work a little harder, makes me problem solve a little bit better. We talked earlier about how we have stereotypes of leaders in leadership, whereby we see decisive leaders as being competent leaders, effective leaders, and people who come across as ambivalent as indecisive or incompetent. But there's also been work looking at how leaders who are ambivalent are able to take in more information about complex situations. Can you talk about this work?
复杂的问题，我们正在独立工作，正是这种情境让你的矛盾让我工作更努力一点，让我解决问题更好一点。我们之前讨论过我们对领导力和领导者的刻板印象，即我们将果断的领导者视为称职的领导者、有效的领导者，而将那些表现得矛盾的人视为优柔寡断或不称职的人。但也有研究探讨了矛盾的领导者如何能够吸收更多关于复杂情况的信息。你能谈谈这项工作吗？
I mean, what is the upside of ambivalence when it comes to leadership? Yeah, so I just really love this research where we have been exploring both in experimental laboratory context as well as in the real world with consultants. Now, what is the effect of having a leader who's torn and conflicted, who's ambivalent about a project? And what we have found across these three separate studies
我的意思是，当涉及到领导力时，矛盾的好处是什么？是的，我真的很喜欢这项研究，我们在实验实验室环境以及与顾问的现实世界中都在探讨这个问题。现在，拥有一个纠结、冲突、对项目感到矛盾的领导者，其效果是什么？我们在三个独立的研究中发现
is that leaders who are ambivalent, in fact, seek more information from their team members. And that has this benefit of then modeling a style of leadership that's perhaps more democratic. And the team members start seeking more information from each other and the team performs better compared to when leaders experience less ambivalence. But there's paradox here. So ambivalence is, we punish ambivalence when leaders express them,
事实上，感到矛盾的领导者会向团队成员寻求更多信息。这有一个好处，那就是塑造了一种可能更加民主的领导风格。与领导者经历较少矛盾的情况相比，团队成员开始互相寻求更多信息，并且团队表现得更好。但这里存在一个悖论。所以矛盾是，当领导者表达矛盾时，我们会惩罚矛盾，
but it turns out ambivalence helps make people better leaders. How do you solve this paradox? I have started to answer this question in some of my work. I think this is where the science currently stands, is wanting to understand when, is it going to be fruitful and when is it not? When you have ambivalence and you share it in a highly individualistic competitive situation, it's not going to serve you. But if you can first create cooperative norms where we're on the same side,
但事实证明，矛盾有助于让人成为更好的领导者。你如何解决这个悖论？我已经在自己的一些工作中开始回答这个问题。我认为这就是科学目前所处的位置，想要了解什么时候它会有成效，什么时候不会？当你产生矛盾并在一个高度个人主义的竞争环境中分享它时，它对你没有帮助。但如果你能首先建立合作规范，让我们站在同一边，
that that's the first step for then harnessing the benefits of sharing our ambivalence with others. I'm thinking though, in the political sphere, when you're running for office, I mean, that's in some ways the definition of a zero-sum game, you know, if you win, I lose, if I win, you lose, only one person can win an election. Is it possible that expressing ambivalence in the course of a campaign is in fact dangerous and counterproductive to actually getting elected? But once you are elected, expressing ambivalence, especially within closed door settings, where you're surrounded by other people
那是利用与他人分享矛盾的好处的首要步骤。不过我在想，在政治领域，当你竞选公职时，在某些情况下，那是零和博弈的定义，你知道，如果你赢了，我输了，如果我赢了，你输了，一场选举只能有一个人赢。在竞选过程中表达矛盾是否实际上是危险的，并且对实际当选适得其反？但一旦你当选了，表达矛盾，特别是在闭门会议中，周围都是其他人
who are trying to come to the right decision on a matter of policy might actually be effective. So in other words, is it possible that we need to be strategic not just about when we experience ambivalence, but when we express it? Oh, yeah, I love that. And so we have shown in some research recently that, yeah, you're not going to promote the
试图就某项政策问题达成正确决定的人，实际上可能是有效的。换句话说，我们是否不仅需要对我们何时经历矛盾保持战略性，还需要对我们何时表达矛盾保持战略性？哦，是的，我喜欢这样。所以我们在最近的一些研究中表明，是的，你不会去推广
ambivalent leader, but you know what? They actually are also perceived as more ethical. They actually also are more likely to take the perspective of their employees, right? And in fact, be more effective once they get there. There's also been some really fascinating work here Naomi, looking at how ambivalence might change how we orient ourselves towards the meaning of life, how much meaning we derive from life. Can you talk about this work?
矛盾的领导者，但你知道吗？他们实际上也被认为更具道德感。实际上，他们也更有可能采取员工的角度，对吧？事实上，一旦他们到达那里，就会更有效率。这里还有一些非常迷人的研究，娜奥米，着眼于矛盾如何改变我们对生命意义的定位，我们从生活中获得多少意义。你能谈谈这项工作吗？
What's the relationship between experiencing ambivalence and being able to derive greater meaning from our existence? Yes, so there's this really fascinating research by Rao Barrios and colleagues that is kind of inspired by some writing that Jeff Larson did several years ago, who argued that when you have mixed emotions, it allows you to kind of take both the good with the bad. And in the research by Rao, found found that in fact when you have mixed emotions,
体验矛盾与能够从我们的存在中获得更大意义之间有什么关系？是的，劳·巴里奥斯及其同事有一项非常迷人的研究，它受到杰夫·拉森几年前的一些著作的启发，他认为当你拥有混合情感时，它允许你兼顾好坏两方面。在劳的研究中，发现事实上当你拥有混合情感时，
perhaps in the face of contradictory goals, that you also are more likely to experience Udamanic well-being, which is a form of well-being that is rooted in meaning-making. So essentially, it finds that there's this importance of having mixed emotions in the search for meaning in life and for resolving our conflicted goals. So in some ways, being able to see that we are pulled in different ways allows us in some ways to see the complexity of the shades of life, if you will, and perhaps see how rich that tapestry can be. I think that's exactly right. When we come back, how to put ambivalence to work in your own life? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Is ambivalence a good thing or a bad thing? Turns out my answer to that question is ambivalence.
也许在面对相互矛盾的目标时，你也更有可能体验到尤代蒙尼亚式的幸福，这是一种扎根于意义创造的幸福感。因此，本质上，它发现混合情绪在寻找人生意义和解决我们冲突的目标方面具有这种重要性。所以在某种程度上，能够看到我们被不同的方向拉扯，在某种程度上使我们能够看到生活中各种阴影的复杂性，如果你愿意这么说的话，也许能看到那幅挂毯是多么丰富。我认为这完全正确。当我们回来时，如何在你的生活中发挥矛盾心理的作用？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。矛盾心理是好事还是坏事？事实证明，我对这个问题的回答是矛盾的。
Ambivalence can help us see the world more clearly and act more creatively, but it can also make us feel uncomfortable and seem weak. Naomi, you grew up with a model of someone who productively used ambivalence in his daily life. Who was this person and where did his love of ambivalence come from? Yes, so I've been thinking long and hard about how my father influenced me with respect to my own research. And so, yeah, my dad was this guy from New York. He spent several years in the late 60s and 70s working towards a PhD in Renaissance literature
矛盾心理可以帮助我们更清晰地看世界，并进行更有创造力的行动，但它也会让我们感到不舒服，显得软弱。娜奥米，你在成长过程中接触过这样一个模范人物，他在日常生活中富有成效地运用了矛盾心理。这个人是谁，他对矛盾心理的热爱从何而来？是的，所以我一直在深入思考我父亲是如何在我的研究方面影响我的。所以，是的，我爸爸是来自纽约的家伙。他在60年代末和70年代的几年里致力于攻读文艺复兴文学博士学位
at UC Berkeley, where he met my mother. And he actually never finished his dissertation because he was drawn away by a larger purpose to teach writing at UC Santa Cruz. And he saw this as a way to give people voice and thereby kind of support their participation in democracy. And he was just beloved. He was beloved by his students. He was beloved by his colleagues, his bosses, hundreds of people came to his memorial service. And they wanted to speak about kind of the impact,
在加州大学伯克利分校，他就是在那里遇到了我母亲。事实上，他从未完成他的博士论文，因为他被一个更宏大的目标吸引走了，那就是去加州大学圣克鲁斯分校教授写作。他认为这是一种赋予人们发言权并以此支持他们参与民主的方式。他深受爱戴。他的学生爱戴他，他的同事、老板们爱戴他，数百人参加了他的追悼会。他们想谈谈他的影响
his impact on their lives and how he changed their lives. And in a few cases, people even told me that he saved their lives. So you can imagine he's taught me many things, but two pivotal lessons were about ambivalence. The first was to identify ambivalence in the world. And the second is the value of ambivalence as a leadership strength. So my dad taught me to identify ambivalence in the world. And the second is the value of ambivalence as a leadership strength.
他对他们生活的影响以及他是如何改变他们生活的。在某些情况下，人们甚至告诉我，他救了他们的命。所以你可以想象，他教给我很多东西，但其中两个关键的教训是关于矛盾心理的。首先是识别世界上的矛盾心理。第二个是矛盾心理作为领导力力量的价值。所以我爸爸教我识别世界上的矛盾心理。第二个是矛盾心理作为领导力力量的价值。
So my dad taught me to identify ambivalence through Shakespeare plays. During my childhood, we went to like every single Shakespeare play performed by Shakespeare Santa Cruz. And I'll never forget this other thing that my dad used to do all the time. I went to college at UC Davis. And when he would drive me to campus, there's an exit near
所以爸爸通过莎士比亚的戏剧教导我识别矛盾心理。在我童年时期，我们几乎去看了圣克鲁斯莎士比亚剧团表演的每一部莎士比亚戏剧。我永远不会忘记我爸爸经常做的另一件事。我在加州大学戴维斯分校上大学。每当他开车送我去校园时，附近有一个出口
Fairfield, California called Cordelia. And so without fail, every time we drove past this exit, my dad would always retell the story of Cordelia in King Lear. And it's the story of a complex relationship between a father and a daughter. Lear asks for professions of love from his three daughters to determine basically how to divide the land of his kingdom between them. And Cordelia's sisters, Gonerol and Reagan
加利福尼亚州的费尔菲尔德，名叫科迪利亚。因此，每次我们开车经过这个出口时，我爸爸总是会无一例外地重述《李尔王》中科迪利亚的故事。这是一个关于父亲和女儿之间复杂关系的故事。李尔要求他的三个女儿表达爱意，以此来决定如何在她们之间划分王国的土地。科迪利亚的姐姐戈纳丽尔和里根
give deceitfully lavish speeches that basically profess their love, flatter his vanity, right? And Cordelia basically sees right through her sisters feign professions of love and kind of refuses to do the same. And Lear deems her answer as too simple. And he asks her, what can you say to draw a third more opulent than your sisters speak? And Cordelia replies, nothing, my Lord,
发表了虚伪而华丽的演讲，基本上表达了她们的爱，迎合了他的虚荣心，对吧？而科迪利亚基本上看穿了她姐姐们假装的爱意表达，并拒绝做同样的事。李尔认为她的回答太简单了。他问她：“你有什么可说的，能比你姐姐们说的更丰厚三分？”科迪利亚回答说：“我的大人，什么也没有，
unhappy that I am, I cannot heave my heart into my mouth. I love your majesty according to my bond, no more, no less, and lear than exiles her as a response to her honesty. And so clearly, there's just like a lot to unpack here, but especially as the daughter of somebody who totally was beloved by so many people, right? But one of the things that I learned from these conversations was to notice ambivalence,
真不幸，我无法把我的心捧到嘴里。我按照我的责任爱陛下，不多也不少。”作为对她诚实的回应，李尔流放了她。所以很显然，这里有很多东西需要剖析，但尤其是作为一个被那么多人深爱着的人的女儿，对吧？然而，我从这些对话中学到的事情之一，就是注意到矛盾心理，
to notice it in relationships, in emotions, in the world, and that ambivalence, contradiction, complexity are just a core part of our lived experience. And it deserves to be noticed. He also taught me the value of ambivalence, and particularly for leaders. And he did this through his interpersonal style. So, you know, like you might wonder what in the world does this even look like. Well, my dad often sounded like he was quite torn and conflicted. He would rarely just agree or disagree. My mom has said that this could be rather frustrating, but he was resistant to taking sides.
在人际关系中、在情绪中、在世界上注意到它，而矛盾心理、矛盾、复杂性正是我们生活体验的核心部分。它值得被注意到。他还教导了我矛盾心理的价值，特别是对领导者而言。他是通过自己的人际交往风格来做到这一点的。所以，你知道，你可能想知道这到底是什么样子的。嗯，我爸爸听起来经常显得非常纠结和矛盾。他很少只是简单地表示同意或不同意。我妈妈说过，这可能会相当令人沮丧，但他不愿意选边站队。
He was uncomfortable with premature certainty. And in fact, on his tombstone, we have a quote from Shakespeare's play, as you like it, which is much virtue in if. And the full quote is, your if is the only peacemaker, much virtue in if. And so this really epitomizes him as an educator, as an administrator, as a father. You know, he was really just at his best in conversation with other people. He was so curious. He was so ambivalent.
他对过早的确定性感到不舒服。事实上，在他的墓碑上，我们刻有莎士比亚戏剧《皆大欢喜》中的一句名言，那就是“‘如果’里面有很大的美德”。完整的话是：“你的‘如果’是唯一的调停者，‘如果’里面有很大的美德。”所以这真正概括了他作为一名教育工作者、一名管理者、一位父亲的特质。你知道，他在与其他人交谈时确实处于最佳状态。他是如此好奇。他是如此充满矛盾心理。
He was so open-ended. He loved to ask hard questions. He would often start his senses with things like, well, what if? Or perhaps, or I wonder. And there was just so much virtue in it, right? He actually helped people work through difficult problems. And so, you know, it's totally undeniable
他是如此开放。他喜欢问难题。他经常以这样的话语开始他的句子：“嗯，如果……会怎样？”或者“也许”，或者“我想知道”。其中蕴含着如此多的美德，对吧？他实际上帮助人们解决困难的问题。所以，你知道，这是完全不可否认的
that his interpersonal style inspired my research on the benefits of sharing your emotional ambivalence. So, researchers have found that people who, like your father embrace what's sometimes called a paradox mindset are able to use ambivalence effectively. What exactly is a paradox mindset Naomi? This is this fascinating research conducted by scholars, including Ella Miren Specter, Amy Ingram, Josh Keller, Wendy Smith, Maryann Lewis, who suggested that if you develop a paradox mindset where you consider the world with a both-and approach,
他的人际交往风格激发了我对分享情感矛盾心理的好处的研究。因此，研究人员发现，像你父亲那样接受有时被称为“悖论心态”的人，能够有效地运用矛盾心理。娜奥米，究竟什么是悖论心态？这是由学者们进行的一项引人入胜的研究，其中包括埃拉·米伦·斯佩克特、艾米·英格拉姆、乔什·凯勒、温蒂·史密斯、玛丽安·刘易斯，他们提出，如果你培养了一种悖论心态，用一种“既要-又要”的方法来看待世界，
instead of an either-or approach, it can be really helpful for dealing with competing demands. And so one assumption is that competing demands, like the ones that people have really experienced through the pandemic, are very uncomfortable. And what these authors found was that, are very uncomfortable. And what these authors found was that, you know, although tensions tend to arise when you have these competing demands, the tensions themselves are not the problem. It's actually people's mindsets.
而不是“非此即彼”的方法，这对于处理相互竞争的需求会非常有用。因此，其中一个假设是，相互竞争的需求——比如人们在疫情期间真正经历过的那种需求——是非常令人不舒服的。而这些作者发现的是：是非常令人不舒服的。而这些作者发现的是：你知道，尽管当你面对这些相互竞争的需求时，紧张感往往会出现，但紧张感本身并不是问题。真正的问题其实是人们的心态。
And if people believe that addressing one demand means neglecting another, that they're gonna struggle. But with a paradox mindset, people accept and they learn to live with the tensions that are associated with their competing demands. And they realize that one demand can actually enable another and that they might need both of them to thrive. In many ways, I think the paradox mindset might be the solution to a problem that we discussed earlier, which is that ambivalence is a naturally uncomfortable state. Many of us try and simplify the problems we're seeing
如果人们认为满足一项需求就意味着忽视另一项需求，他们就会苦苦挣扎。但有了悖论心态，人们就会接受并学会与伴随相互竞争的需求而来的紧张感共存。他们意识到，一项需求实际上可以促成另一项需求，并且他们可能需要这两项需求才能蓬勃发展。在许多方面，我认为悖论心态可能是我们之前讨论过的一个问题的解决方案，即矛盾心理是一种自然的不舒服状态。我们许多人都试图简化我们看到的问题，
to come down on one side or the other. But of course, we've also seen that ambivalence allows us to see the world in all kinds of complex, interesting, and creative ways. And so the paradox mindset says, if you can increase people's capacity to tolerate the discomfort of ambivalence, you can derive the benefits of ambivalence, you know, without being overwhelmed by the discomfort of it. Is that sort of summarizing the idea? I think that is summarizing the idea beautifully. And I think it's actually still a hypothesis. I think we we're still wanting to unpack right exactly the role that paradox mindset might have in helping people harness
从而倒向某一边。但当然，我们也看到，矛盾心理让我们能够以各种复杂、有趣和有创意的方式看待世界。因此，悖论心态的意思是：如果你能提高人们忍受矛盾心理带来的不适感的能力，你就能获得矛盾心理的好处，而又不会被这种不适感所压垮。这样总结这个观点可以吗？我认为这个总结简直完美。而且我认为这实际上仍然是一个假设。我认为我们仍在努力剖析悖论心态在帮助人们利用
the benefits of ambivalence and in deal with the discomfort. So there are some situations where deliberately cultivating ambivalence can be a way of managing or limiting disappointment. Can you talk about that, sort of using ambivalence almost strategically to head off disappointment or the head off feelings of failure or setback? Yeah, so this is this really interesting research where people, in fact, are found to cultivate ambivalence when they face uncertainty about what will happen, right?
矛盾心理的好处以及应对不适感方面可能发挥的确切作用。因此，在某些情况下，刻意培养矛盾心理可以成为管理或限制失望情绪的一种方式。你能谈谈这个吗？也就是近乎战略性地利用矛盾心理来预防失望，或者预防失败感或挫折感。是的，这是一项非常有趣的研究，事实上，人们在面对未来会发生什么的不确定性时，会被发现会培养矛盾心理，对吧？
So perhaps they feel uncertain that they can obtain like a coveted job. And in order to protect their feelings in the event that they fail to get what they want, they create a mixed emotions or mixed attitudes as a self-protective strategy to buffer their feelings from failure. I have had experiences in my own life where I have done this as well. Can you talk about them Naomi?
所以也许他们对能否获得一份梦寐以求的工作感到不确定。为了在未能得到自己想要的东西时保护自己的情感，他们会创造出混合情绪或混合态度，作为一种自我保护策略，来缓冲失败对他们情感的冲击。在我自己的生活中，我也曾有过这样的经历。娜奥米，你能谈谈这些经历吗？
Absolutely. So it's kind of a funny story, I mean now in retrospect, right, which is that when dating my spouse, I really wanted it to work out with him, but I was of course uncertain if it would, because you just never know. And I remember going on vacation with my brother's family, and while I was away for that week, I built up these very mixed feelings about my spouse. And it's obvious now to see that it was definitely a self-protective strategy in the face of possible rejection. I was preemptively protecting myself by cultivating ambivalence. And I actually think that it made both my spouse and myself think more deeply about the
当然可以。所以这是一个挺有趣的故事，我是指现在回想起来，对吧？那就是在和我的伴侣约会时，我真的很希望这段关系能成功，但我当然不确定是否会成功，因为你永远无法预知。我记得我和我兄弟的家人去度假，在那一周我离开期间，我对我的伴侣产生了这种非常复杂的感情。现在很显然可以看出，在面对可能的拒绝时，这绝对是一种自我保护策略。我通过培养矛盾心理来先发制人地保护自己。而且我实际上认为，这让我的伴侣和我自己都对
other person to really see each other, to see both the positives and the negatives, and whether we were a match. And I actually would say I was accurate. He's my favorite person. And perhaps my ability to predict our match was cultivated by my emotional end of events. In some ways you did with him, what you didn't do with the house in Bucks County, you know,
对方有了更深入的思考，真正地看到了彼此，看到了积极面和消极面，以及我们是否真正般配。而且我实际上会说我的判断是准确的。他是我最喜欢的人。也许我预测我们是否般配的能力是由我的情感矛盾心理培养出来的。在某种程度上，你对他的做法，和你对巴克斯县那栋房子的做法不同，你知道，
you by by allowing yourself to to engage in ambivalence you were able to see things perhaps more clearly and in the long run that might have actually been an asset. I think you're so right. You know, I'm struck by the fact, Naomi, that that your research in some ways has been inspired by events in your own life, but also you have taken this trans of your research and tried to apply it to your own life, to experiences you've gone through yourself. I'm wondering if you can tell me about the time when your mom was really sick and how you applied the insights from your own research to what your mom was going through.
通过允许自己陷入矛盾心理，你也许能够更清晰地从长远来看待事物，这实际上可能是一种资产。我觉得你说得太对了。娜奥米，我深有感触的一点是，你的研究在某些方面受到了你自身生活中事件的启发，但同时你也采用了你研究的这一主线，并试图将其应用到你自己的生活中，应用到你亲身经历过的事情上。我想知道你是否能告诉我，当你的妈妈病得很重时，你是如何将自己研究中的见解应用到你妈妈所经历的事情上的。
Certainly. So, a year and a half into the COVID pandemic, my mother noticed that she had some shortness of breath and months later they diagnosed her with early stage lung cancer. And she was not somebody who had been a smoker, but her parents had also had lung cancer. And she was going to have surgery. I flew out to support her through this surgery, and we were sitting in the hospital room, waiting five hours for the surgeon to be ready. And I remember feeling these waves of anxiety. You know, I kind of noticed that I kept having the urge to amplify my positive emotions and to suppress my worry
当然可以。新冠疫情爆发一年半后，我母亲发现自己有些呼吸急促，几个月后，他们诊断她患上了早期肺癌。她并不是一个吸烟者，但她的父母也曾得过肺癌。她要做手术。我飞过去陪伴她度过这次手术，我们坐在病房里，等了五个小时才等到外科医生准备好。我记得当时感到了阵阵焦虑。你知道，我注意到自己一直有一种冲动，想要放大我的积极情绪，压抑我的担忧
and my anxiety. And when I was younger, I would often amplify my positive emotions and I would suppress my negative one. I used to have these mantras that I kind of wrote on little soccer balls and gave to my friends, which was like, it's what you make of it or make the best of it or mind over matter, right? And, you know, I think that that was a more kind of
和我的焦虑。当我年轻的时候，我经常会放大我的积极情绪，压抑我的消极情绪。我过去常有一些座右铭，我把它们写在小足球上送给朋友，比如：“事情取决于你怎么看待它”或“把事情做到最好”或“精神战胜物质”，对吧？而且，你知道，我认为那是一种
or less mature way of kind of dealing with my emotions, but not an uncommon one. And so what I had found was that these mantras didn't really help. And in this moment in the hospital room, I kind of caught myself trying to do this cheerleading along the lines of you're doing great. Good job, mom. You know, these like kind of throw away positive affirmations that we kind of so frequently use to kind of manage the moods in the group or in the room. And what I have learned to do is to actually process my negative emotions instead of suppress them.
或多或少更成熟的应对情绪的方式，但并不罕见。所以我发现这些座右铭并没有真正起到作用。在医院病房的那个时刻，我发现自己试图沿着“你做得很好”、“干得好，妈妈”的思路来扮演啦啦队角色——你知道，这些我们经常用来管理群体或病房情绪的随意的积极肯定。而我学会做的是去实际处理我的负面情绪，而不是压抑它们。
It's something that I practice. It's something I'm pretty intentional about, noticing my feelings, identifying them, and being curious about them. And so what I found myself doing in my mom's hospital room was to just stop and to notice that I was having this inclination to kind of amplify the positive and suppress the negative.
这是我一直在练习的事情。这是我非常刻意去做的事情，去注意到我的感受，识别它们，并对它们保持好奇。所以在妈妈的病房里，我发现自己在做的事情就是停下来，注意到自己内心有这种想要放大积极面、压抑消极面的倾向。
And I don't want to judge people for doing that. But I think for my mother and myself, it's just not true to us. And so I wanted to honor the truth, I think, of the emotional situation, the situation we found ourselves in in the hospital room, and perhaps, like Cordelia, I didn't want to lie. And what did you say to her? What did you say to your mom? How did you express the negatives? I said, mom, you know, I'm noticing that I'm having this inclination to one cheerly to you, and to boost us up, and it's because I'm anxious, you know, I'm feeling worried, and I wanna do my best
我并不想评判那些这样做的人。但我认为对于我和我母亲来说，这并不真实反映我们的内心。所以我想要尊重情感状况的真相，我们在医院病房里发现的那种状况的真相，也许就像科迪利亚一样，我不想撒谎。你对她说了什么？你对你妈妈说了什么？你是如何表达负面情绪的？我说：“妈妈，你知道，我注意到我有这种倾向，想要对你扮演啦啦队角色，给我们鼓劲，那是因为我很焦虑，你知道，我感到担忧，而我正在尽最大努力
not to just suppress that. And what was the effect of doing this on your mom, do you think, that you were expressing not just, you know, you're cheerleading and optimism, but also putting in place the context of your anxiety and worry? You know, if my own experience tells me anything, it's that when people acknowledge their mixed feelings in an honest and real authentic way, that it's comforting to others, particularly
不仅仅是去压抑这种情绪。”你认为这样做对你妈妈有什么影响？你不仅表达了（你知道的）啦啦队的乐观，还将你内心的焦虑和担忧的背景融入其中？你知道，如果我自己的经验能说明什么的话，那就是当人们以诚实、真实的方式承认他们复杂的感受时，这会对他人起到安慰作用，特别是
to those who are also feeling emotional and bivalents or mixed feelings, that it's completely normal and natural. Do you feel like your mom felt that way? I mean, did you say anything by the before or since that acknowledged to you that in fact, she did find it helpful for to hear you express both the positive and the negative? Yeah, so my mother in the moment
对那些同样感到情感矛盾或复杂感受的人来说，这完全是正常和自然的。你觉得你妈妈有这种感觉吗？我是说，在此之前或之后，你有没有说过任何话，让她向你承认，她的确觉得听到你同时表达积极和消极的情绪对她很有帮助？是的，我母亲当时
doesn't often share her feelings, but she does this beautiful thing where she sends me letters and notes. I asked Naomi to read me the letter her mother sent her after the surgery. She writes, Dear Naomi, in the conversation we had, I felt so totally seen and understood. I felt as though you know me deeply better than anyone in my life now. Thank you for being the intelligent, probing, compassionate person you are. I feel so blessed and proud to be your mother.
并不经常分享她的感受，但她做了一件很美好的事，那就是给我写信和便条。我请娜奥米读给我听她母亲在手术后写给她的信。她写道：“亲爱的娜奥米，在我们刚才的交谈中，我感到自己被彻底看清和理解了。我感觉你对我有着深刻的了解，比我现在生活中的任何人都更懂我。谢谢你成为这样一个聪明、敏锐、富有同情心的人。作为你的母亲，我感到无比幸运和骄傲。
I feel as though you found your way to carry on dad's work in the important contribution you have to make. About the difficulty and the importance of embracing ambivalence and holding off premature certainty. Love Mom. Naomi Rothman is a psychologist at Lehigh University. Naomi, I can say this without ambivalence, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
我感觉你已经找到了继承父亲遗志的道路，并做出了重要的贡献。关于拥抱矛盾心理以及拒绝过早的确定性的困难与重要性。爱你的妈妈。”娜奥米·罗斯曼是里海大学的心理学家。娜奥米，我可以毫无矛盾地说，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. This week for our unsung hero, we thought we'd turn the mic over to a listener and share a story from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. Today's story comes from Jackie Briggs. The moment that changed Jackie's life came on a Saturday afternoon in August 2006. I was attending what was built as a woman's health conference. Turned out it was really a pitch for cosmetic surgery, which really irritated me, but turned out it was really a pitch for cosmetic surgery, which really irritated me. But anyway, at that point in my life, I was 52 years old.
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周对于我们的无名英雄，我们决定将话筒交听众，分享我们姊妹播客《我的无名英雄》中的一个故事。今天的故事来自杰基·布里格斯。改变杰基一生的时刻发生在2006年8月的一个星期六下午。我当时正在参加一个被称为女性健康会议的活动。结果证明这实际上只是一场推销整容手术的活动，这真的很让我恼火，但结果证明这实际上只是一场推销整容手术的活动，这真的很让我恼火。但无论如何，在那个人生阶段，我52岁了。
And for several years, I'd been working 60-hour work weeks in this high-pressure IT job, and I had very little time for myself. So I really wanted to go and hear this one particular speaker. As a few hundred women milled around different booths, picking up brochures, and eating cruditees offered by those black panted, white, churred, weight staff, this lovely dark-haired woman came up to me and she said, excuse me, but I can't help but notice your arm. I had what my boss later described as what he thought was a rose tattoo. It was on my upper right bicep. And I was uncharacteristically wearing a sleeveless dress that day.
多年来，我一直在这份高压的 IT 工作中每周工作60小时，我几乎没有自己的时间。所以我真的很想去听这位特定的演讲者发言。正当几百名女性在各个展位间闲逛，拿取宣传册，吃着那些穿着黑裤子、白衬衫的服务人员提供的开胃菜时，一位可爱的黑发女性向我走来，她说：“不好意思，我忍不住注意到了你的手臂。”我的老板后来形容这看起来像是一个玫瑰纹身。它在我的右上肱二头肌上。而我那天很不寻常地穿着一件无袖连衣裙。
Well, this woman who I have come to refer to as Angela, although I really don't know if that's how she introduced herself or if that's the name I have since given her. But she asked me if I'd seen a dermatologist about this smallish, irregular, almost birthmark looking spot, and I assured her I had. She pressed me and said, when? And I had to stop to think and I counted back the months and no years. It had been over three years. I was supposed to follow up a year after, but I was so caught up in my job I never did.
这个我后来称之为安吉拉的女人——虽然我真的不知道她当时是不是这样自我介绍的，还是这只是我后来给她的名字。但她问我是否看过去看皮肤科医生，针对这个小小的、不规则的、看起来几乎像胎记的斑点，我向她保证我看过。她追问我说：“是什么时候？”我不得不停下来思考，我倒数着月份，不，是年份。已经三年多了。我本该在一年后去复诊的，但我太专注于工作了，一直没有去。
The dermatologist's office never reached out to me, either so blah, blah blah blah time moves on. So this woman urged me to call my doctor Monday morning first thing. Please don't wait," she said. She explained she was a nurse for a plastic surgeon and as she gently touched my arm she said, really, don't wait. And thanks to her, I didn't wait. In the following weeks of Drs. Appointments biopsies and then the surgery are all a bit of a blur, but because everything moved very fast. But my melanoma was removed and my six inch ragged scar that travels almost from the
皮肤科医生办公室也从来没有联系过我，所以巴拉巴拉巴拉，时间就这样流逝了。所以这个女人敦促我周一一大早第一件事就给医生打电话。“请不要等，”她说。她解释说她是一名整形外科医生的护士，当她轻轻触碰我的手臂时，她说：“真的，不要等。”多亏了她，我没有等。在接下来的几周里，看医生、做活检然后是手术，这一切都有点模糊，因为一切进展得太快了。但我的黑色素瘤被切除了，那条从
top of my shoulders, down my arm, is my everyday reminder of her, Angela, my guardian angel. She saved my life. Melanoma is a cancer that metastasizes faster than any other except pancreatic, and if I hadn't listened to her, I probably wouldn't be here. So to my hero, Nurse Angela, thank you for my life. Jackie Briggs of Portland, Oregon. She tells us that about two years after that conference and her melanoma surgery, she
肩膀顶部一直延伸到手臂的六英寸长的不规则疤痕，成了我每天对她的提醒——安吉拉，我的守护天使。她救了我的命。黑色素瘤是一种转移速度比除了胰腺癌之外任何其他癌症都快的癌症，如果我没有听她的，我大概就不会站在这里了。所以，致我的英雄，护士安吉拉，谢谢你赐予我生命。来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的杰基·布里格斯。她告诉我们，在那次会议和黑色素瘤手术大约两年后，她
quit that 60-hour a week IT job. She also took up mountain climbing and submitted 12 peaks. When we spoke with her, she was happily retired, going kayaking, hiking, and motorcycle riding whenever possible. If you enjoy hidden brain or myon- Sang Hero, please consider supporting our work financially. Find out how by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Hundreds of listeners have already shown they have our back. Please consider joining their ranks.
辞掉了那份每周工作60小时的IT工作。她还迷上了登山，成功登顶了12座山峰。当我们与她交谈时，她已经愉快地退休了，只要有可能就会去皮划艇、徒步旅行和骑摩托车。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》或《我的无名英雄》，请考虑在财务上支持我们的工作。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 了解如何支持。数百名听众已经表明他们支持我们。请考虑加入他们的行列。
It will mean so much to our team. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedatam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这对于我们的团队意义重大。再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。